oh [ __ ] here it's about that time your
mother [ __ ] made the right choice
here pilot the bunker near pilot the
bomba theme
there is no clarity pilot the bumper
dear
there is no clarity pilot to
[ __ ] bumper dear
if you ain't blowing class like that
you're slipping [ __ ] uncle Joey
here get ready for a deep afternoon you
like Joey where the [ __ ] you've been off
their been busy mother [ __ ] make a
mousse talk of the people get lied to
but I don't give a [ __ ] the whole time
I'm stoned to the gills thinking I got
this [ __ ] he don't even know it
yet you understand me I did some jumping
jacks I wanted you jittery I choked out
good today I saw some [ __ ] stars but
that's what it's all about now I'm gonna
cage and they just struggling [ __ ] at me
in about two hours they let me move she
understand me that's the [ __ ]
mentality right there I have a laugh at
you now I gotta go put on a suit now and
go talk to some people my main man Renee
and costs young my main man the [ __ ]
Jew from Canada with the [ __ ] dragon
little [ __ ] I'm giving you shout outs
right now cuz we're going deep am I
forget listen sometimes I got 15 weeks
sometimes I got one today oh [ __ ]
I don't know what this is does it
[ __ ] matter does it matter I'm
shattered should do be do let's smoke my
number on a [ __ ] of respect Joe nice
this is very nice evil a nice the birds
a choker the wind is blowing most
importantly you're alive God gave you
another day the sling dick that's the
most important they always got you
another day cuz you're not optional
oh yeah
there you go there you go battling you
man who's better than you your smoke
weed and you hear sirens that's happened
to me right
we're coming when you smoke weed in your
Cyrus you got to go back and get another
eight that [ __ ] when you're a hip now by
the way if you watch the podcast last
night all Benjamin's alive and kicking
listen like the wu-tang clan those
doesn't that mean that the [ __ ] would I
don't give a [ __ ] with your friends tell
you about anything else listen I've been
smoking dope doing age doing blow I
gotta go get surgery out of my nose to
get the old blowout from the [ __ ] I
got that Pablo Escobar [ __ ] blowing
my nose asian you guys what huh huh we
watch Pablo I [ __ ] to get to [ __ ] out
of him I was snorting I was Pablo's
number 3 customer understand anybody
that's in the past as the future which
mike s smell of far from time to time
sometimes you blow good for get yogurt
you wanted hell on a plane I can't smell
it the [ __ ] my point is that
I don't know what my point was let's
just get high and shut the [ __ ] up ooh
look at that little [ __ ] clouds in
the [ __ ] take me dealing with these
[ __ ] apple fruit cakes and Hollywood
me tattoo needs to get the [ __ ] out of
here I don't want weed that kill him to
its I want that small murder like a
black dick up your ass you never black
dick up here as a slow [ __ ] murder
one minute you [ __ ] giggle the next
minute you seen Frederick Douglass and
drag that's what happens anyway we're
here we're queer you're part of his
smokin if you down some [ __ ]
man fun I don't do no 420 n ku4 20 24 7
that's how flavor doesn't gotta get the
poker
that's it taking this [ __ ] the
death
oh yeah
what do another why not just waited
[ __ ] deadly
this boat to him it's just a real deer
right him
ok
let's go [ __ ] I gotta pick the baby up
at five-thirty I gotta go talk to some
[ __ ] beat with three thirty in it
unbelievable it never ends but I'm
rocking and rolling [ __ ] out of
respect for you [ __ ] you know
why cuz we were always the last ones in
line and then picked us they picked the
other kids it's great to stand back
there and go walk back here [ __ ] we got
something for you oh oh you don't have
to go home oh you don't have to go you
don't have to go bye but I bye but I bye
boba Colorado in the [ __ ] house I
love it North Baltic when you drive by
the police station beep the horn out of
respect uncle Joey since love i love
boulder police department and the reason
why I'm [ __ ] here
they crack the case lacroix total joke
Leah
what are you gonna Sam wait here was
smoking a bowl you know getting [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the ass by Isis thing you're
making it happen so you know why no you
may not
I hear what Uncle Joe
I am
another boy for the yacht oh yeah oh
yeah we're going deep [ __ ] I'm
out to cancer that medium and sirens
ambulances I'm living in Apocalypse Now
didi Mau same [ __ ] Vietnamese people
you see Vietnamese people's alone
because i am in longueuil jolie saddle
give a [ __ ] check
taking this deep into the murky water
oh yeah
lake
now we'll expended my rib cage was doing
little exercises about the beliefs
anyway
I'm stoned to the gills down howa
copters are coming we don't want no
problems I gotta go put a suit on and
we'll get back to my white people know
how that goes what the Gentiles trying
to tell me something I don't [ __ ]
know you got to get up early in the
[ __ ] water to deal with flavor
that it's [ __ ] band of soldiers
anyway
we'll do one of these later right as you
can tell I'm done this is some good
[ __ ] truth you got a minute mother son
saw terrible and get the [ __ ]
Disneyland and tunnel uncle Joey [ __ ]
cent you're right that's how I roll also
a shot up to speed we do you want to
leave the house from scratch your balls
and sniff your fingers
these [ __ ] in friday flopping
around any minute now Charlie Sheen
gonna be on my front porch I love your
[ __ ] sucked to stay black I hope you're
stoned I don't just broke up the
afternoon for you oh yeah get that mom
and my bean dollar city